defense secretary James Madison's the
mission in nazir that ended in the
deaths of four US Army sergeants is
still under investigation
Jeremiah Johnson Brian Black Dustin
Wright and la David Johnson were not
expecting in make contact when they were
attacked earlier this month the
Americans were ambushed by a group of
about 50 fighters affiliated with Isis
Senate Armed Services Committee members
want more information they may use a
subpoena to get it David Martin is at
the Pentagon David good morning good
morning this started out as a low-risk
patrols of 30th of its kind to meet with
local village leaders but it has turned
into one of the most controversial
controversial military operations of the
Trump administration loss of our troops
is under investigation as the Pentagon
probes the death of four American
soldiers killed in Neesha our members of
Congress are now also calling for their
own investigation
we're co-equal branches of government we
should be informed at all times Pentagon
officials say an American reconnaissance
aircraft was in the air but not watching
over the patrol who was only called in
after the Ambler started three soldiers
were killed and a fourth sergeant la
David Johnson was missing officials
believed he was still somewhere on the
battlefield for several hours they
tracked a locator beacon that became
intermittent and finally faded out by
the time they found him two days later
he was dead raising the awful
possibility an American soldier had been
left behind it's a possibility the
Pentagon is Lieutenant General Kenneth
Mackenzie flatly rejected no one's left
behind either u.s. our partner friend
partner Nigerian forces or French forces
were on the ground actively searching
for this soldier according to defense
secretary mattis the first
reinforcements to arrive were French
aircraft 30 minutes after the ambush was
reported the French response included
fighter aircraft armed fighter aircraft
armed helicopter gunship medevac helo
that lifted out our wounded the first
American aircraft to arrive was an
unarmed helicopter sent to recover the
bodies of the American soldiers it was
operated by a u.s. contractor
to provide support for American troops
operating in new year there are about
eight hundred troops American troops in
Nazaire that may sound like a lot except
Bashar is a country the size of Texas
there they're on a counterterrorism
mission that as secretary Mathers said
yesterday in that kind of mission every
patrol even one on which there are no
contact is expected carries a risk Gail
you saw that thank you very much David